-Our next guest is
an Emmy-nominated actress
you know from films
such as "Joker"
and "The Harder They Fall."
She's starring in the third
season of "Atlanta,"
which airs Thursdays on FX
and streams on Hulu
the next day.
Let's take a look.
-What the hell's wrong with you?
-What?
-Where have you been?
-[ Sighing ]
I've been shopping.
I was thinking
about how Grace Jones has
all these like male suits
and I kind of wanted one.
I also got this really cool
like '80s wig.
-It's been weeks.
You give me a thumbs-up emoji?
Are you serious?
-You guys are busy.
You're working.
I was just kind of doing
my own thing.
It's not really that big
of a deal.
I mean, you guys didn't plan
for me to come here.
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Zazie Beetz,
everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back!
-Thank you!
-You look wonderful!
It's so wonderful to have you!
-Thank you.
Thanks for having me around
for the third time.
-The third time here.
And it's always nice
to have you
because you are a New Yorker.
You grew up here
in New York City.
I have a question for you
because I'm now raising
New York children.
[ Laughter ]
-Good luck.
-And I was a suburban child.
And so for me, 16, the thing
every kid in the suburb
looked forward to at 16
was getting a driver's license
and I feel like New York kids,
that wasn't the case,
necessarily.
-No! Absolutely not.
I got my license
three years ago.
My mom got hers a year
after I got mine.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. And she is older.
-She's older than me.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And I think back
to like high school,
I think, if I remember,
out of my whole class,
only one person got their
license and he drove to prom.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoa.
-Everybody was like, "Yes!"
-It made it worth it.
-The thing about "Atlanta"
that's fascinating --
it's been four years
since the last season,
which is both way too long
and also,
the minute it came back,
it was familiar and comfortable
and wonderful.
Like it is such a special show
in that it didn't --
You were immediately
right back in it.
But even you, as a cast member
in the show, were waiting.
-Yeah.
-You had an instagram post of --
This is basically
you made some reference
to the fact
this is how you felt,
waiting four years for "Atlanta"
to come back on.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it was a long four years.
-It was a long four years.
Now, I have a question
about one thing in this picture.
Do you want to guess what it is?
-The, um,
masks on my ears?
-Yeah! So,
[ Laughter ]
you have two.
Those are masks.
-They are masks.
-Because you misunderstood
the rules about COVID.
[ Laughter ]
-So, actually,
during Season 3,
he cast had a --
well, we were really bonding,
so we had a tattoo
and piercing party
and I'm not tattooed,
but they all got matching
tattoos for the show.
And I was, like, "I don't want
ink, but I'll get pierced,"
so they got a piercer for me
and I got my second
lobe piercings.
But it took so long
for them to heal.
Like this, I think,
is nine months in
-That's way too long, right?
-and I was so frustrated.
It's supposed to take
like six weeks.
And I was so frustrated.
They kept getting irritated,
so I was like,
"I'm sleeping with masks
on my ears."
You know, I don't know.
I was desperate.
[ Laughter ]
That's the pandemic for you.
And so that lasted
a couple of weeks
and, yeah, I've moved on.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you now have some
follow-up questions
for the piercer they found you,
that they brought in,
who did this excellent work?
-[ Laughs ]
I mean, she was British, so,
maybe they just do things
differently there.
[ Laughter ]
-With the exchange rate,
it heals longer, yeah.
-Yeah, exactly, so.
[ Laughter ]
You shot an episode --
you shot a season in Europe
and you shot an episode
in Amsterdam.
I used to live in Amsterdam.
Did you enjoy the city?
-I did.
It's interesting
because New York is
New Amsterdam,
so some of the architecture,
I found, was sort of similar,
I guess like the brownstone
sort of thing.
And I actually recently met
another comedian
who also spent a year
in Amsterdam.
Is that like a thing?
-Yeah, there was a comedy place
over there, so I bet it's --
-Like it's a little random.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a little random, yeah.
Yeah, there's this comedy
theater called Boom Chicago,
so I bet it's somebody, yeah,
that I probably
crossed paths with.
-I was actually surprised
at how diverse it was.
I wasn't really expecting that.
And, you know, it's very --
I think it's beautiful.
It's very sterile.
-Yes.
-It's very like they're very
organized and very --
and there's a reason, I think,
why people like it, but.
I think I'm a little grungier.
[ Laughter ]
But it was nice.
I did enjoy it.
-You have family in Germany.
-Yeah.
-You used to visit there
every summer.
-Yeah.
-I know it was the middle
of the pandemic,
but did you get
to visit some family?
-I did.
Right after we
finished shooting,
my 30th birthday was coming up,
so I went and and did it
with my grandparents.
They're getting older,
so I don't know how many
birthdays I have with them.
My mom was upset about that
because I wasn't home,
but I'm glad I got to do it
with them
and my dad was able to come.
So, yeah,
I was in Germany for that.
-That's nice.
We've talked in the past
about your younger brother
-Fifteen now.
-is a fan of your work
Fifteen now.
And like at the time
that we first talked,
a lot of what you did maybe
wasn't age-appropriate for --
might've been 10 or 11
at that point.
-Yeah.
-And how's he doing now?
Is there stuff you're doing
that he's into?
-I mean,
he's into everything now,
which is so fun to share.
I think my mom let him watch
"Deadpool,"
[ Laughter ]
but, you know.
-I mean, if your sister's
in "Deadpool,"
you got to watch "Deadpool."
[ Laughter ]
-And I mean, at that age,
it's not like they're like not,
you know --
What are they doing in school?
Who knows?
[ Laughter ]
No, my six year old,
we walk to school
and he hears all the words.
-Yeah. He knows all the words.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I'm sure one or two
slipped out by now.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah, my brother,
he loves "Invincible" a lot.
That's an animated show
that I do,
but it's an adult animated.
It's on Amazon.
Check it out.
[ Laughter ]
And "Deadpool."
I mean, I think, now,
as he gets older, too,
I think a lot of this stuff
probably went over his head
and now I think he can engage,
maybe, a bit more,
I guess better
with the material.
But, yeah, I mean,
I'm excited to,
to just continue to share
that with him.
And I just did a children's
movie, "The Bad Guys."
-Oh, there you go.
-Yes.
-I'm very excited.
My kids are very excited
about "The Bad Guys."
-Do they read the books?
-No, but they've seen the poster
and they're just super
into the idea.
They hate books.
[ Laughter ]
No.
-They don't?
-No, I know those are super
popular books for kids, so,
maybe we'll do that, first,
and then go see the movie.
-It's kind of like I think
it's like an introduction
to the heist genre for children.
It's like "Ocean's Eleven,"
but animated.
-See, we taught them
to steal even younger.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, good. My dad did the same.
My dad forced me to steal
a Starburst from a store once.
-Really?!
-Yeah.
And I felt really bad about it.
He was like, "Do it!
It's good!"
[ Laughter ]
I think he wanted
to build my character.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow, I feel like we got
to something at the end
that we probably could've used
like another hour to unpack.
-Yeah.
-Does your dad know?
Is this the first time
you've admitted this story
about your dad?
-Publicly, yes.
[ Laughter ]
So.
-Did he say afterwards, like,
"Don't tell anybody!"?
-No, I think he was --
I don't know
if he needed the thrill and was
using me as a vehicle for it.
[ Laughter ]
-Gotcha.
-I was eight.
So, yeah.
-The interesting thing is
I don't think there's
a healthier option.
You know, like if you asked him
and he's like,
"No, no, no, it wasn't.
I just needed a thrill for me."
[ Laughter ]
-I have therapy tomorrow,
so maybe I'll bring that on up.
-And the next time you're here,
let us know how you went.
[ Laughter ]
Alright. Great.
Thank you so much.
It's great to see you!
You guys, Zazie Beetz,
everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
New episodes of "Atlanta"
air Thursdays at 10:00 pm on FX
and Stream the next day on Hulu.